hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
chapter 12 of anselm's treatise on truth
is entitled
on the definition of justice de
definizione eustitiai right and this is
an absolutely important chapter it looks
sort of like a digression or an
application
within the treatise on truth itself but
it's going to play
an absolutely
central role in nearly
all of the other major anselmian works
that follow it and can be read backward
into the
monologian and proslogin as well where
we're trying to understand what justice
actually
is and so
anselm and his student are going to
clarify the nature
of justice and they're going to give us
the outlines of a rather robust theory
that ties it directly
and most importantly you know sort of
foundationally
to the will where other types of justice
like justice of action
are going to be derivative of justice in
the will so they begin by talking about
rectitude again and the student says
you've taught me all truth is rectitude
it seems to me that rectitude rectitudo
rightness and justice are the same so
teach me what i should understand it
seems that whatever is right is also
just and conversely whatever is just is
right and he gives two examples here it
seems right and just that fire should be
hot and that each person should love
those who love that person so
you know
is this the the case that justice and
rectitude are the same we know that
they're the same in the highest nature
that is in god
what about in other things and here
anselm is going to lead the student
through realizing that we're actually
using
rectitude and justice in
two different ways and and he says we
could talk about this in a very broad
sense right
a stone falling or fire burning is that
justice in the moral sense not exactly
but in a broad sense we can actually say
that truth
rectitude and justice
mutually define each other say say
definite definient in latin right in
vicum is is used there as well so
there's this this sense that all of
these are connected with each other and
in a broad sense within the world they
all help to
they help us to define them and thereby
to understand them
but
in a stricter sense
we can say that justice
is
when somebody does willingly
what they ought to do and here the
student is going to raise you know
some problems as well we know that the
stone acts naturally
and not by willing right and so anselm
says yeah the stone is not called just
on that account
but only that which does what it ought
to do willingly is just and here the
student will bring up a very interesting
example he says okay
when something does willingly what it
ought to do
what about a horse
when he wishes to go to the pasture to
go eat right since he willingly does
what he does a horse does have a will
and anselm is going to say
yeah
it's it's following its nature
it's not choosing willingly and it
doesn't actually understand
what it's doing so anselm is going to
tell us
that justice
in its moral sense is only in certain
kinds of beings what kinds of beings
beings that know rectitude it's actually
framed in the negative there is no
justice in beings that do not know
rectitude right agnoskit in the latin
but we can reverse it and say
uh
justice is in beings that know rectus so
what would that include well rational
natures which would include us
it would exclude horses it would exclude
stones it would exclude fire
it might include anything else that
would be rational for example it will
definitely include god because god is
not only rational but as we know from
the monologian supreme reason right
but it would also include the angels and
devils and any other rational nature as
well
so
this is a very important point
he says that what we're looking for here
is a definition of justice as in a moral
sense that which merits praise laudazio
and that uh its contrary injustice as
that to which blame the tuperizio is due
and he says um
whatever does not will rectitude even if
it has it does not merit praise for its
rectitude one who does not know it
cannot will it so the horse
because it doesn't know the rectitude
that it's operating according to it
doesn't truly
will it
so he he goes on and he says
where is this then where is this
rectitude within a human being
there's three options
it could be
in the will the voluntas that's where
it's actually going to turn out to be
it could be a knowledge skientia
or it could be indeed
obrazio
or action right and anselm is going to
say it's it's in the will it's not in
knowledge or in the deed why not
well he says what if somebody
understands rightly or acts rightly but
does not will rightly should one be
praised for justice right if you
understand and you don't will rightly
well you're not going to do the thing
that you're supposed to do so
actually doing what you should requires
not only that you know it but that you
will it but what about doing it
without willing it can you actually do
things that you don't will
yes and no i mean if you fall down the
stairs because you tripped up on your
feet or you weren't looking where you
were going or something like that you
don't say oh i willed to fall down the
stairs now some people could will to
throw themselves down the stairs that's
a little bit different we do all sorts
of
actions or operations or deeds that
we're not actually willing and you know
if we're compelled to do something
we're willing it in a sense but also not
willing it in another sense as we're
going to look at in just just a minute
so
it's going to be in the will so we need
to look at justice in the will
what is that going to
look like any
anselm says do you think the justice we
seek is at this point sufficiently
defined
doing what you ought to do willingly
and the student says well you tell me
and so anselm says do you think whoever
wills what he ought wills rightly and
has rectitude of will and the student
brings up some good examples here some
problems
if anyone unknowingly
does what he ought to for example if
somebody unwittingly locks out someone
who wants to kill another person in the
house
whether or not they have some rectitude
or will he doesn't have what we're
looking for you would just say well that
was really fortunate that you locked the
door there we're not praising you for
having uprightness of will you just
happened to do the right thing at the
time right if i'm walking along and you
know there's a bank robbery going on and
i'm like punching in the air because i
like to do shadow boxing and the robber
comes out and i punch him in the jaw
knock him out well that's just an
unfortunate accident right you don't
praise me for having the right will
and then anselm says okay what do you
say about
the person who knows he ought to will
what he wills
and then the student says ah we can have
another kind of case here it can happen
somebody knowingly wills what he ought
to you but doesn't will it because
he ought to and this is a really
important
distinction here right when the thief is
forced to return the money he has taken
it's clear he doesn't want to he's not
willing to
give the money back in in some sense
right he is also he is indeed willing in
the sense that like he makes a decision
to give the money back because otherwise
maybe they punish him or kill him
or something like that but he doesn't
want to and therefore he's forced to
want to return it because he should but
he is in no way
praised for his rectitude
anselm gives another great example here
a person who feeds the poor out of vain
glory wills what he ought to will namely
the right action of giving the
things to the poor
is he on that account praised for
willing to do what he ought what do you
make of him and the the student says
this rectitude notice he's saying it is
rectitude it is doing the right thing
ought not to be praised and therefore
does not suffice for the justice that
we're seeking so we've got some problems
it's not just doing the right thing
it's not even just willing to do the
right thing there has to be something
more
going on here and so anselm's going to
introduce a really
important distinction here
he says we can think about
willing what we ought to do that's sort
of the bare minimum
if you want to have justice in the will
you actually have to will to do the
right thing the the thing that you ought
to do in those circumstances and don't
worry over much about how do we define
that there's other places where he goes
into detail about that but then
we also have
another part of this
willing for and we can translate it as
for the reason for the motive
uh the mindset however you want to frame
it we can even talk about it as the
because or the why right or the on
account of
willing
what you're doing
for the reason that you ought to do that
and so there's quote debits right what
you ought to do or what what should be
the case and then there's quia
debit
because it ought to be the case there's
he uses also the word propter uh and
proper ollywood in this actually on
account of something
but the broader idea here is that
there's on this account for the sake of
we have the as one great ann selman
scholar has talked about it a
objective and a subjective side to this
right and they both need to be there
in order for you to genuinely have
justice in the will
and some
will say uh
that both of these are necessary for
justice and the will
willing what it ought and for the reason
it ought to and then he asked the
student all right have we arrived
at where we need to be tell me if this
is enough
and then the student says well why why
wouldn't it be and see here aunt salmon
is going to reveal to us something else
he says when someone wills what he ought
to because he is forced
does he not in some way will what he
ought to because he ought to
and
the student says yes but he wills it in
one way and the just man in another so
consider the case of the robber right
the robber is willingly giving back the
things that he's stolen but he doesn't
really want to and why is he doing it
what's the queen here
it's because he wants to avoid
punishment
or you know
preserve his life or something like that
so we can get a little bit more specific
about the
because the why here and this is
something absolutely central to anselm's
moral theory
so the student says this
when the just person wills what they
ought to they preserve rectitude of will
for no other reason than to preserve it
so rectitude of will
is being
valued as something that needs to be
preserved rectitude of will
is supplying the propter the quea debit
here the on account of why is the person
choosing to do this because it is the
right thing and they recognize that it's
the right thing and they want to
do the right thing because it's the
right thing
now by contrast one who wills what he
ought to only when forced or persuaded
by some
external reward can be said to preserve
rectitude not for its own sake
but for
the sake probeder
something else
and think consider the case of the
vainglorious person
you could say it's something external
right i give money to the the beggars
and i'm like everybody look at me look
at the charity i'm giving right and so
that external thing that reward of
people saying oh what an awesome guy he
is right that's external
but it's also internal i want that warm
fuzzy feeling of people liking me and
being able to say that i'm a cool guy or
generous or whatever it is right and so
it could be internal as well but it's
not and this is the key thing
rectitude
for its own sake so
in order to be fully just
to have justice in the will
the person has to
have the right motive that of preserving
rectitude
not for the sake of something else but
for its own sake recognizing that this
is something valuable it doesn't have to
be framed necessarily in their mind with
the word rectitude or rightness or
anything like that
they could just say doing the right
thing or they could say well i want to
be you know a good person there's lots
of ways of framing this i mean you could
even like go on and perhaps jump ahead a
number of centuries to a manual [ __ ] and
like you know talk about the categorical
imperative which i think would actually
you know fit into this in a certain way
anselm is not a proto-conscience by the
way but there are some similarities
there
and so
he asks the student
therefore the will is just when it
preserves rectitude for the sake of
rectitude itself and the student says
yes either that or no will is just and
then he says therefore
justice is rectitude of will preserve
cervata for its own sake and we get to
this lapidary formula in latin retitudo
volontatus proper say cervata every
single part of this is important
rectitude rightness
of will not just of intellect or action
say servata preserved maintained
enacted you could even say if we get a
little bit metaphorical with this for
its own
sake so there's a referentiality here uh
rectitude of will that is preserving
rectitude of will in its very operations
and then there's a very interesting
discussion here that helps clarify some
things anselm says we we need to worry
about this preserved
if there's only justice of will when
rectitude is preserved then what about
when we don't yet have it uh nor and he
says we don't acquire justice when we
acquire it but we cause it to be justice
by preserving it and so he says listen
we need to
be clear about our our language and our
thought here
preserving sirvanda right or serbare
acquiring uh possessing
and receiving and some will say for us
these are all simultaneous as soon as we
have received justice in the will we are
willing to
maintain or preserve it
we possess it we acquire it at that time
and he so he says
temporary they are at the same
time
which is a very important classification
somebody could worry or quibble that
when do i actually get this justice how
do i you know how does the causality and
temporality work out here
there's two other points that i think
are very important to stress he also
talks about
the supreme justice
right
and he says can this definition be
adapted to the highest justice insofar
as we can speak of it
of which nothing or little can properly
be said this is the divine this is god
right and he says
this is the student although his will
and his rightness don't differ
just as we say that the power of
divinity or the divine power or divinity
is able
since in divinity there's no difference
between power and divinity
so
not unfittingly it's appropriate it's
not perfect to talk this way but it
works
to say
to speak here of the rectitude of will
or voluntary rectitude or
right will and then he says you know in
a certain way
this definition applies
even more to god than it does to our own
will
how so he says
if we say that this rectitude ought to
be preserved for its own sake
then there's nothing
that fits this better than
god god maintains god's own rectitude
god would never lose rectitude but god
maintains that just by being
god
it doesn't preserve something else but
itself not by something else but by
itself so not for the sake of something
else but for the sake of itself very
cool idea there
the last thing that he clarifies is when
we're talking about human beings what
are we saying well we talk about the
just of heart
right the just are sometimes said to be
right of heart or just of heart and
anselm says what does this mean
right in will
and sometimes we just say simply right
without mention of heart because no one
who does not have a right will
is understood to be
right so for anselm there is an absolute
priority
of the will when it comes to the justice
of a human being and anything else that
we want to call just their actions
states of affairs
relationships all of that is connected
to justice and the will and he's
provided
a
quite robust and
well thought out
definition
of what justice
in the will
would consist in
rectitude of will preserved for its own
sake
you